c'est toujours terrible sait pas quoi
faire en intro les amis je vous ai
demandé sur twitter de m'envoyer des
dessins en rapport avec moi et notre
univers youtube sur le hashtag squeeze
fan art
alors les fans art c'est pas nouveau je
reçois tous les jours depuis plusieurs
années je voulais en vidéo rendent
hommage un peu aux gens qui font ça
parce que c'est du temps c'est des
compétences et puis je pense que ça vaut
le coup de maître sa devant projecteurs
finalement ou sous le projecteur c'est
mieux parce que devant le projecteur il
est pas sous la lumière donc là
l'expression ne marche pas finalement
regardons tous ces dessins ensemble et
merci on commence avec un dessin simple
et efficace
on dirait une fille excellent il est
très bien je vais pas critiquer au
[ __ ] squeeze fanarts jumbo nous manque
alors déjà tu l'insultant métaux en inde
et au début de son prénom ce cas pas de
17 jeunes beau mais ça s'écrit jumbo et
ensuite ce chat sur cette photo est bien
plus beau que et n'est certainement pas
djomo ça c'est tout simplement angora
attention je suis un fils de [ __ ]
critique bd ça aujourd'hui c'est bel et
bien un angora ok maintenant je te mets
un jumbo voilà ça n'a rien à voir il est
beaucoup plus moche mais tagnon hockey
au continuo dit dans des pains youtuber
qui s'appelle tuto draw [ __ ] il s'est
fait chier
qu'est-ce que je suis bonne longueur et
j'aurais pu choquer mais qu ise ado
profite pour passer un petit mot voilà
j'ai vu la communauté des gens qui font
des fanarts peut-être un peu énervé
parce qu'il ya plein de gens qui
s'amusent à taper nanananère sur google
et à voler littéralement le dessin voilà
et le poster sur les régions vont aux
gens que c'est lui même qui l'a fait ne
fait pas ça c'est vraiment pas cool pour
les artistes respecter leur travail
voilà ou alors crédité les si vous
utilisez leurs dessins comme cette
personne vient de le faire donc c'est tu
te diront qu'il avait fait alors voilà
mon squeeze fanarts désolé je les fais
vite cheveux qu'on a fini par aimer ça
me touche je super beaux arts est gérée
lis tes passions au [ __ ]
merci julieta chaparro ça fait du jeu
last guardian j'ai pensé que ça ferait
chaud au coeur alors ça par exemple
c'est obligé c'est un mec qui a
totalement volé ce fan art mes mecs nous
fait pas ça je sais pas qui a fait ça
nan mais en tout cas c'est très bien
tricot et squeeze moi c'est tellement
touchant un grand bravo à branne pour
sauter ça alors là on est sur un dessin
de qualité similaire d'accord donc tu
m'as fait qu'un corps de cheval déjà
considérable c'est un morpion pas des
abdos ok + 1 pour la blague qui m'a
ferrero la la j'ai passé plus de quatre
heures dessus et s'est tiré d'une photo
que j'ai apprise au japon dans un bar à
chiba où il y avait deux chiba en plein
air qui était trop mignon voilà je mets
les photos tu me rassures s'aggrave
n'hésitez pas auto promo calais comme
personne ne l'avait vu auparavant ce
magnifique où là beaucoup trop
d'éléments squeeze aide squeeze le
pervers de l'époque [ __ ] c'est ça ce
que les trucs de mes anciennes vidéos
avec la lampe et où on se souvient tous
à la nostalgie elle est présente trop
alors site référence à mon logo
tubes actuels petite référence au hand
szpiner qui fait plaisir ou pas tricot
dans le fond aéro même si j'adore man
bob l'eponge ce que je doublais deux
mois de mobylettes ont le talent le nom
de référence c'est fou la lampe avec des
ailes moi même ici présents avec la
tenue que j'ai essayé pendant live déçus
prévient on s'en souvient ce domaine
d'élection
enfin sentir hyper cool bravo fanic
windsor ont du talent mais c'est fou on
voit par cette personne mais sinon les
autres vous avez tous du talent au sein
pas bravo axel et c'est lui qui le post
fait tu n'es pas accès pourquoi volent
tuent des [ __ ] de dessins sur google
je sais pas si c'est un filtre ou un
vrai dessin des fois vous fait des
dessins tel ans qu'il est que je ne
serai pas dire c'est un filtre ou pas
c'est horrible mon salaire de squeeze
n'est pas dans mes photos peut-être
parce que c'est un commentaire jeunes
encore habitué à twitter mais ne t'en
fais pas l'urée et nous l'avons vu il
est extrêmement beau job n'a jamais été
aussi stylée d'ailleurs on dirait un
type de la zapa mondiale est plus un
chat domestique nous leucate et écrasées
il est super bien à [ __ ] et du level
mon gars se fait plaisir au [ __ ] ils
écoulent dames et y en a vous prenez un
dictionnaire voilà je vais écrire tous
mes vidéos et en une heure vous faites
un truc mais mais quand en disant j'y
arriverai pas le faire aa c'est lourd à
dictionnaire [ __ ] l'anglo puis qui
fait mal mais c'est pas un fan c'est une
photo alors attends je vais donner la
différence entre les deux
dès sa représentation aux suggestions
des objets sur une surface à l'aide de
moyens graphiques et une photo
autographiée procédés techniques
permettant d'obtenir l'image du rap des
objets par l'action de la lumière sur
une surface sensible est clair c'est à
l'arrêt qu'il dit ceci est donc une
photographie s'est perdu oh là là mais
mec tu m'a détruit le visage
j'espère ne jamais avoir ce visage un
jour à moins d'un accident de voiture ça
devrait pas arriver mais [ __ ] [ __ ]
mec mais mon iphone l'accident de la
déformer grand rigole c'est beau un
moment on a le droit de s'amuser je
proviens va les médécins squeeze au plus
tard de merde je regarde pas les seins
alors là comme tu m'as [ __ ] le nom je
regarde pas le dessin où il est beau je
leur pose parce que j'avais oublié ma
signature
sarah choo bah tu fais bien de mettre
une signature je vous invite d'ailleurs
tous les artistes à faire ça en petits
comme ça c'est discret au moins on pour
accréditer la bonne personne en voyant
wada il m'a fait tellement style est
vrai que j'en étais j'ai les cheveux qui
sont blonds un peu comme ça mais
remercie pour son art en tout cas oui
oui oui
le crav il est bâti tu là il n'est pas
là il est là sur le côté waouh [ __ ]
c'est fait à quoi ça s'est fait au fur
et à leur sort des termes que j'ai
appris un art plastique 6e bon on est
sur du jumbo du jumbo carrément
améliorée voilà la version finale en
couleur royale est super bravo alors ça
c'est une photo c'est pas du tout un
dessin dois je rappeler la définition de
la photographie nord je n'aurais pas
quitté pas la vidéo c'est bon ça c'est
très mignon avec ses petits poils qui
ressemble fortement des poils des
aisselles wa il est fou bar mais il ya
plein de gens qui savent carrément bien
dessinés coiffe et des artistes mes amis
alors squeeze j'ai parti du principe que
quand tu te fais chier a passé quatre
heures à faire un dessin tu sais écrire
le pseudo de la personne pour qui tu le
fais florent imposteur ouah [ __ ] étape
après étape
tu fais une sorte de petits croquis ou
les traits sont pas nets ensuite tu
repasses en faisant un très bien- être
ensuite tu ajoutes de la couleur et
ensuite tu ajoutes un emoji wahaha c'est
fou heures de mix entre jumbo et rick
aux génial tribaux va l'appelait alors
ça c'est ce qu'on appelle un filtre
in-stat g jean-michel trucage
après tout je ne sais pas dessiner bien
tenté j'avais déjà commencé le squeeze
preneur il ya quelques mois du coup je
définis pour l'occasion on dirait
totalement diablo choqué mais pas déçu
un à un petit dessin de ma joie au clip
placement de produits nominés ont très
vite dans un terril et vous adorez
méchas vous aimez plus mais chaque moi
même c'est fou j'ai pas le temps de
finir mais je trouve que ça te ressemble
déjà un peu paumé par contre extrêmement
glauque 1 waouh alors déjà je manquais
tombe freiner le décor je peux finir
renvoyer si tu veux parce qu'il est
moche la non mais arrête m'énerve ça les
artistes qui font ça l'a respecté vos
plus tard c'est magnifique
un artiste quand il fait un truc est
obligé de dire m & spa ouvre ta gueule
tu sais très bien ce que tu as fait le
teint et confiance en vous
trop bien et les manies vitter jeu le
fawe ans [ __ ] mais pourquoi ses passes
et a eu un bug sur paint faisait
contrôler jette ça marchait plus trop
tard loyers comme ça tu as fait exporter
je lui envoie dans le doute
wouah [ __ ] vous êtes trop talentueux
mais la vidéo c'est que ça c'est moi qui
fais wa trop fort et trop stylées
ouah macri jackie chan le crabe et avant
des éléments qui vous ont marqué dans
les vidéos c'est marrant vous retenez
vraiment ça vous les mettez sur vos
dessins coiffés en trois heures ne jugez
pas il est pas super but que j'ai 13 ans
et encore beaucoup de défauts mais
arrêtez de vous critiquer il est très
bien en dehors du fait que j'étais
toujours les cheveux et des énormes
kandel mais sans savoir qu'il est très
bien là c'est cool down boas d'accord le
respect morsay d'hommes modem on a
bouffé depuis tout à l'heure mais je
peux bien finir ma partira il est très
très bien ce dessin bravo camille jeu
permet de reposer mon squeeze fanart
pour qui ce quiz ils voient ça
représente beaucoup de travail
bah bravo très stylée j'aime bien comme
il ya vraiment des styles différents
selon les artistes c'est vraiment fou
avec jumbo vous ne faites toujours plus
mignon qu'est ce qu'il est c'est trop
drôle et attachant
il est tellement bête et naïve j'aime
trop on ne change rien à sa coupe
squeeze pas tarder je sais pas si ma
réaction c'est bien au fait que le
dessin et stylet ou au fait qui met
détruit la vie de la coupe de cheveux
maquillage le prend il est incroyable
d'envoyer lui-même il a vraiment sa
touch quoi c'est vraiment puissant à
dire un mec qui fait des caricatures
dans le journal je passais un complément
ce que j'ai dit mais dans ma tête
c'était un compliment
bravo glock et non pas matteo ciboulette
qui s'amuse à le voler et dont le nom de
famille est en fait une épice à il a
dessiné mon bureau jumbo ici [ __ ]
c'est mignon ça alors les visages y
avait les y avait la foule m je leur
fais de mes propres mains
mais je te crois pas ce pauvre mec se
fait voler son dessin 18 fois quoi c'est
dû au fait comme ça je suis fan art il
doit paraître en premier et voilà bravo
cox blogueurs et des anticorps et sur
son blog et j'adore il a été fait en
2015 en plus il ya deux ans dessin mais
il est très bien bravo boxe à elle être
cool cela m'a fait tellement pitié que
je ne me suis vraiment génial le micro
avec le bras les grands écrans génial ça
me fait penser à un professeur sakamoto
où je peux quand il s'appelle c'est la
meilleure vidéo du monde
oui ça tombe bien en gros c'est un mec
dans un lycée proche parent ce sujet
mais en gros c'est un mec dans un lycée
qui a trop la classe qui est vraiment il
ya trop de charisme il est trop fort et
légendées fois qu'ils aient dû faire du
petit coup de [ __ ] donc là il répond
parfaitement à une question du prof
alors il est très précis et deux à lui
l'album il va il va faire la blague du
jeu tiens tiens ta chaise
kia motors tintamarre classe que quand
il retire sa chèvre il est quand même
assis dans le vide regardez ça va trop
fait pendant un an le crabe aux éditions
[ __ ] fanas de mes abonnés assez génial
il a vraiment créé un univers crabots
navy a eu 7 millions monte à doha a
devancé will you tube heures lagos qui
sait trop bien et trop d'imagination
bravo nommé en référence à la vidéo on
doit jouer staline
moi aussi mon petit fana qui s'inspire
des propagande communiste à l'époque de
staline en espérant qu'il plaise aux
futurs j'ai pas vu mes joueurs c'est le
tatouage kraft sur les drapeaux super
bien fait bravo ça c'est moi en mode
comment il s'appelle
[ __ ] comment elle s'appelle à eau
son nom est le meilleur mais vous avez
fait car dans le dessin j'ai adoré de
dessiner le dessin c'est ma passion
j'espère que tu vas à l'aimer mais la
vérité c'est que c'est un filtre
instagram sur lequel tamis l'option
d'ébruiter à 100%
[ __ ] les mecs un squeeze hamon qui
évolue tu penses mais quand sera comme
ça à la gastro il a vu le futur os 4
heures j'aurai totalement cette gueule
avec une grande moustache comme ça doit
une szpiner non annoncés on a tous je
veux pas mal de dessin actuellement qui
n'ont pas les partages qu'il mérite
merci les voleurs surtout continuer il
avait une image du jeu de type hawaïen
il suivait avec celui qui a été plus
volées de tous quoi s'amuser pauvre box
quoi on aime en mode johan cornelia
olalalala sais pas si vous connaissez
cette artiste c'est des huîtres h et
voilà il fait il fait tous ces persos
comme ça oh là là mais là y'a trop
niveau là d'un coup qu'est ce qui se
passe là haut avec l'iss you in tutoriel
d'enjeux c'est mignon j'ai pris des
jours mon gars j'ai pris 6 kilos il est
très bien
environ 58 travail j'ai mis tout mon
coeur il est super [ __ ] référence à la
vie de veine szpiner il est vraiment
trouvé un bravo melanie c quoi c'était
tout en vo mais tape out
oh c'est bon en fait les jeux de lumière
ça embellit tellement indécent krynda
jeu vidéo
il apparaît le nom du mec il a mis le
cas à y en a qui sont malins pour
contourner la loi allait bokassa j'aime
bien ce style [ __ ] bravo méga design
il est hyper bien moi et mon frère c'est
vous comme vous arranger donner 20 sauf
pour mon frère le grand saut
nekochan dessin bien jouer hayal crabe
ici donc je sais que c'est bien moi que
tu a dessiné en venant du japon ce qui
nous a gâché sa nouvelle passion
banderole imposé suite à de nombreux
fans à revoler ici tu as très bien fait
n'hésitez pas à marquer votre nom sur
les dessins et moi je protège tous les
artistes maria kouao vous n'avez pas
envie de m'adopter vous adoptez qui
entre les deux batteries qu'au bien sûr
pas [ __ ] tu aimais sur le cul il est
tellement réaliste mec attaques de ce
front la taille de ce bras il est fou à
[ __ ] bravo nelson enfin si tu es
vraiment le créateur il n'a pas volé où
étais-tu tout à l'heure à 14h tu peux
m'envoyer ton historique par screen s'il
te plaît pour finir j'aurai un petit
dessin vous montrez moi on exclut ça va
être rigolo mais voilà j'en suis super
fier deux heures de travail quand même
butin le problème c'est que c'est pas
moi mais ce n'est vraiment bien celle
qui j'ai fait une peinture à l'huile
vite fait en dix minutes juste pour
participer doit mec c'est le schéma
était des talons comme ça de peindre
c'est fou
wahou max nous a fait un fan art digne
des plus grands mercis maxence tient et
puis j'ai d'autres desseins de toute
beauté sur la chaîne youtube si jamais
par audi sport sa chaîne youtube et
c'est absolument magnifique ce dessin
est beau de toute beauté
bravo mec allez hop on dirait une photo
mec c'est fou mais c'est une photo mois
pour les cheveux les cheveux tu as des
tours et attend une vidéo je rêvais d'un
commando là tu passes à la version
colorée on dirait une photo est sain que
quelqu'un fait à ça je veux voir comment
comment tels que la couleur ok tu fais
une couche comme ça uniforme
ainsi tu tape dedans pour éclaircir les
endroits manuellement merci tu fais ça
avec toute la pompe et c'est fou merci
j'avais un pareil avec les cheveux et tu
seras boala mais là mais c'est
incroyable m et le talent alors je veux
juste vous montrer les fan art qui ont
été faits il ya un moment que j'avais vu
et j'ai jamais pu remercier ce qu'il
avait fait hu alors déjà il ya le
gribouillis qui avait fait un truc de
malade avec plein de youtube heures il
ya aussi eu suis là à l'époque qui était
complètement dingue et 2014 l'ancien
haut il est bien celui-là c'est vite à
un bon jeu et launay bord celui-ci qui
est complètement ouf aussi par 7e fin
bref sur des montagnes a vraiment des
gens qui vivent aux des dessins
régulièrement des fanarts donc merci à
tous ces gens aussi et merci à tous ceux
qui ont participé sur twitter c'est ma
fille hyper chaud au coeur vous êtes
bourrés de talent c'est dingue mais
comme pro mais attention je vais vous
montrer un truand fait je devais refaire
le décor est un moment mais je n'ai
toujours pas fait froid je le fasse et
je voulais affiches et ça c'est quelque
chose que j'ai ramené de monde et les
voyages au japon avec mon frère et mon
père
c'est tout simplement une caricature de
mon frère mon père et moi en one man
show man dbz et naruto voilà je vous le
montre notamment ce sera affichée plus
tard la bd japonaise qui était bourré de
talent dans un centre commercial et j'ai
craqué je me suis dit vas-y obligé au
film carrie capture elle fait ça
vraiment la meuf en dix minutes c'est
impressionnant bon après la pause en
tant que vous mais bon faut pas lui dire
merci à tous d'avoir participé je suis
désolé si on a comparu leurs desseins
passé dans la vidéo mais j'ai reçu
tellement de dessins que j'aurais dû
faire une vidéo de 28 heures pour tous
les montres et merci beaucoup dans tous
les cas que si vous avez fait un dessin
que ça vous est pris dix minutes ou huit
heures c'est hyper millions vote pas ne
voulait jamais des dessins d'autres
personnes seront pas cool pour eux c'est
rarement du taf et c'est dur de se créer
une communauté etc
et quand tu te fais voler comme ça
gratuitement ça fout les boules ne
faites pas ça ce jeu vous défonce moi
même bien la caméra elle même elle vous
défoncer que c'est un sale [ __ ] et vu
que c'est la fois change pas la batterie
je vous dis au revoir sur fond noir
allez salut
[Musique]